[Music]
hello come on back there I'm sorry I
know then what's that bong in the
backseat
Oh donk that's funny that's a sculpture
that I I made in school I don't know
what the [ __ ] you're thinking driving
around with a bong in the backseat of
your car what do you think you are
Willie Nelson
maybe he got arrested really time is a
terrible way of speeding by my mom wrote
that to me in a letter when I was eight
okay I got a dump out she believed you
like [ __ ] at school I'm only having
two weeks left with you guys know what a
dick it what are we gonna do next year
are we doing like cool brooding winter
drugs like opium together near each
other okay my little cruise director
okay would you rather have penises the
fingers or vaginas for years dick
fingers you cannot wear Ramon's but you
have vaginal ears you could wear
earrings
no but when you just know you're not
gonna be a professional athlete I kind
of had one tonight
yeah well the moment that you had comes
a little later for black folk
yes I get you though I do my you and I'm
going to Columbia we're gonna be like
brighteners forever I don't even know if
that's 100% I wanna do what I need my
dudes where the [ __ ] is Lily I know I
know I should close here too
unless our token white friends ironic
[Music]
donkey bone there with us through high
school life death SATs wrong we should
be us like when you know things are
ending you freak out you better hold on
and if you get so wise that's right if I
really want it aren't you supposed to be
in my class right now aren't you
supposed to be in your class right now
this never happened
[Music]